fue otra noche dolorosa para muchos
ucranianos especialmente en la provincia
de kiev harquive y Nitro según las
autoridades ucranianas 17 misiles y 31
drones fueron lanzados durante la
madrugada en kiev lograron ser
interceptados pero no así en las
provincias de harqui fideni Pro donde
cayeron al menos siete misiles Y al
menos unos ocho drones alcanzaron a
impactar sus objetivos pero el momento
más dramático se vivió ya durante la
mañana a partir de las diez y media de
la mañana cuando un hospital en la
ciudad de deni Pro fue impactado Pues
quedó prácticamente destruido hay una
persona muerta al menos una persona
fallecida Y al menos 15 heridos pero se
siguen buscando personas desaparecidas
dentro de los escombros y esto recuerda
también otro ataque a la población civil
en esta ciudad el pasado enero uno de
los más dolorosos y más difíciles que ha
vivido este país desde el comienzo de la
invasión a gran escala también el
gobernador de la provincia de llamaba la
atención sobre el ataque en la madrugada
a la ciudad de izum Tal vez una de las
más afectadas y más destruidas desde el
comienzo de esta invasión en febrero del
año pasado el dice que fueron impactados
algunas fábricas y también áreas civiles
y dice que tal vez fue el ataque más
duro que ha vivido esta ciudad desde
entonces lo que hace más o menos dar una
perspectiva de la dureza del ataque que
se vivió a partir de esta madrugada del
lado ruso también acusan a Ucrania o
aseguran haber recibido dos ataques en
dos provincias de la provincia de rostov
hablan haber interceptado un misil y en
la provincia de granadar hablan de que
uno drone alcanzó área residenciales y
de oficinas sin embargo desde Ucrania no
han confirmado ningún